what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so for this week's what if story I
figured we do the story of what if the
sentry killed the Marvel Universe now
this actually comes out as a what-if
story as a counterpart to siege which is
actually issue number 200 it's actually
pretty cool but for those of you guys
who don't know I've done a video on
siege which you'll find down in the
description but the basis of this was
really like the conclusion of everything
that had come after Civil War I mean we
had the superhuman Registration Act we
had Secret Invasion we had Dark Reign
where Norman Osborn had replaced Tony
Stark as director of shield and Norman
Osborn had looked to basically take over
the world
the idea of siege brought all these
things to an end so it saw the
disbanding of the superhuman
Registration Act it saw the defeat of
Norman Osborn it saw the death of Robert
Reynolds in the original story the death
of the century this one.if story takes a
different approach
so during Dark Reign Norman Osborn had
basically replaced the Avengers with
villains because for a lot of people out
there they knew about the identity of
some of the heroes where they didn't
know all of them and so for example
Hawkeye was basically replaced with
bullseye Norman Osborn himself took over
the role of Iron Man operating under the
role over under the name of iron patriot
with the Iron Man armor um we had a
multitude of heroes who were essentially
just replaced with the villains and then
Osborn used them as a way to effectively
solidify his reign now we also had
groups like the x-men which were
basically outliers and the sense that
Norman Osborn's control at the time was
really isolated to the continental
United States and so for the x-men they
effectively left the continental United
States they formed their own Society in
a place called utopia off the coast of
San Francisco and they operated outside
a moment Osbourne's control so because
of this they were able to basically try
to for his efforts as best they could
but there really wasn't a whole lot that
they could do because remember this is a
point in the history of the x-men where
the mutant population has been reduced
by 98% so there's only a very small
portion of them left who can effectively
fight against Osborn and so during the
original siege of n Asgard as it existed
in Oklahoma was really like the last
bastion of Norman Osborn solidifying his
rule and then taking the steps to
essentially take over the government and
make himself dictator and so because of
this he had basically brought along a
lot of his a lot of his ilk his cabal
and led a campaign to take over Asgard
now the kicker to this was that you
still had Thor you still had a lot of
heroes who were there you had
Loki who's kind of the hidden hand
behind it all but the idea here was that
Osborne had gone against the forces of
Asgard and he gone against you know the
Avengers under Captain America when they
had realized what was going on and they
basically rallied to the call and so odd
Norman Osborn was essentially defeated
here in this story we take a different
approach in the original siege event or
I guess in the events of Dark Reign
really the event that led up to siege
Norman Osborn had essentially had the
Sentry's wife Lindy killed by bullseye
and then he had used the emotional state
of rubber Reynolds to manipulate him
into following the ideologies of Norman
Osborn
hence having one of the most powerful
beings in existence on his side with
this particular story instead of
fighting Ares they got of war on the
battlefield during the siege of Asgard
instead Robert Reynolds had fought him
several days before him and what this
man was that instead of like the
original siege on Asgard story while
Reynold was basically exhausted after
fighting fighting Ares in this story
he's fully energized he has he's lost
virtually none of his power and because
of this he's quite literally a one-man
army
I mean Robert Reynolds goes through he
kills Luke Cage by punching a hole in
him he kills Thor like he kid
he cuts off the head of Captain America
and it was actually really really messed
up it was it was funny there's not funny
that's not funny the Captain America's
head got cut off that's it is funny cuz
like like scarlet or not Scott sweater
um Spider Woman Jessica Drew's like no
it's hilarious to me but the idea here
is that Robert Reynolds allowed for
Norman Osborn's villains to effectively
go through and start killing off what
was left to the superheroes cause you
gotta keep him on Captain America
despite not having any real superpowers
per se it's like a moral rallying point
for all of the superheroes I mean they
look to Steve Rogers as the one guy that
was solidified and Brian Michael Bendis
is age of Ultron when everything had
come crashing down all the superheroes
were waiting on Steve Rogers to
formulate a plan that's literally what
they were waiting on they were waiting
on him to get his act together to figure
out what to do next they ultimately
settled on traveling to one of Nick
Fury's bunkers when he was still alive
but the idea was you know during age of
Ultron it was established that Captain
America was the rallying guy and it
always been that way that story just
kind of solidified it as being an
absolute truth but with him being killed
here the superheroes haven't really long
their will to fight so much as they've
lost any real measure of organization
and so again we have the Avengers coming
in much like we did before we have
Ironman we have you know Wolverine you
know we have the x-men Cyclops we have
them coming in of course the x-men again
didn't play a major role in the original
events of siege but they're showing up
here but it doesn't matter because
they're all being defeated by you know
Robert Reynolds and by these various
heroes and so the way things begin to
differentiate is Emma Frost effectively
has to watch as Cyclops died but during
this process Doctor Doom arrives dr.
doom steps in and says hey we got to get
out of here like I have magic that's
basically hiding our existence here but
it won't be long before this magic wears
off they realize that we're here and
then they kill us so we've got to bail
out because I have a plan and so she
ends up going with Doctor Doom and they
arrive back at utopia now again utopia
is this area where the extra base of the
operating out up but there's only a
handful of them left now from those who
had originally been killed and so you
know when that when the question is
what's your plan you know what what goal
do you have here were suddenly met by
the arrival of Loki and Loki is the one
that says hey I have a plan I'm the one
that has this idea on how we're going to
fix everything and so at this point we
really just kind of have Norman Osborn
in the background solidifying his reign
in the sense that he informs Carla and
he informs Mac a couple of his henchmen
to basically go and kill the President
of the United States thereby allowing
women Osborn to solidify himself as
absolute ruler of the world we also have
you know bull's eye trying to be dealt
with by some of these other heroes as
well but it's really just this attempt
by them to to eliminate as many of known
Osbourne's heroes as they can before
they end up getting into Robert Reynolds
now following this Robert Reynolds is
actually brought to them by Loki and
this was the plan of Loki himself his
plan was to basically go to riddles and
to say hey bulls I was the one that
killed your wife Norman Osborn was the
one who instructed him to do it now
initially he doesn't believe them but in
frost says hey you know let me use my
powers let me go into your mind and I'll
show you what it is it had happened and
when he sees what took place he
immediately kills her and the reason why
he does is is because Robert Reynolds
transforms into the void
now this is a great time to have that
conversation because I've seen so many
people
that I saw the in the siege comments
there is a siege video people were
asking in the comments section is the
void more powerful than robber rentals
yes Robert Reynolds is it's really kind
of like his powers or sort of a mishmash
there are some that say that he has the
ability to warp reality and that's kind
of been confirmed to a degree in Marvel
Comics there are some that say he's just
super powerful and his power is whatever
the riders need him to do at any one
particular point in time like that is
just what his power is his he has he has
powers of convenience but the idea here
is that Robert Reynolds always has like
a moral compass he always keeps the void
in check the void is all the anger and
all the hate of Robert Reynolds
manifested into a physical being and
it's unbridled power I mean just
unbridled untapped uncontrollable power
in the most extreme and so it's
literally just a force of nature is the
best way to describe the void it is and
it's it's an insane reckoning and we see
this because the void literally kills
everyone
it kills dr. doom now the death of dr.
doom which dr. doom always seems to die
as stories like this but the death of
doctor to whom is so cool because you
know the the void says hey look if you
want a bag you can beg and dr. doom says
nope I don't beg and so void says okay
fine
and just kills him off no questions no
nothing kills off one of the most
powerful mystics one of the most
powerful beings in existence after that
he turns his attention to Norman Osborn
and kills Norman Osborn and so from here
it's basically you know humanity
launching its weapons it's you its
weapons of war it's bombs and so on
against the center gets the void with no
effort whatsoever nothing happening out
of this and after this the void
basically begins going through and
killing all those heroes that just
didn't show up at the siege on a scar
that kills all these beams it just
simply didn't make it to that event for
whatever reason and so what we learn is
that this entire series of events is
actually being watched by a by a member
of the watcher named a tau now this is
actually a deviation from the status quo
in Marvel Comics all the what-if stories
are basically told to us from uatu the
watcher and the reason why was
established again in the original sense
story when he watched The Watcher had
access to see all the other universes
that exists out there and so it was like
we were watching it through the eyes of
the watcher as he was looking at a
viewing screen but what happens is this
is actually another guy named name
how who's you know relaying these events
to a walk to the watcher and the
implication here is that not only does
the void go through and wipe out all
life on Earth and destroy the earth
itself it also seems like the void is
going to eventually destroy the moon and
then make its way through the entirety
of the universe killing everything off
now the question is could the void do
that yes the void could easily go
through and kill the cosmic entities
kill the Celestials kill Galactus
because remember the voids power is
limitless there's no there's nothing the
void can do and so any foe that goes
against the void the void will have
enough power to kill that foe every
single time across the board without
fail this is why this the character of
the century is so derisive in Marvel
Comics and this is you know because he's
really just kind of like a trump card
like century enters the fray and then
whatever side he's on wins but it's also
the other reason why the century and the
comics had always tried to keep the void
at bay because if the void were to were
to go Unleashed like it did here uh then
it would just lead to the destruction of
everything this is really just showing
us what happens when the void when the
century basically lets his guard down
and allows the void to completely take
over and you know what what the
ramifications would be for situation
like that it's just the void wiping out
all things in existence but if you guys
are a new here to comics explain make
sure you guys hit the subscribe button
to become part of the robb cork if you
guys enjoyed this video drop a like and
leave a comment down below let me know
what you guys think about the century
rubber Reynolds we know how you guys
feel about him because I know he's
really popular but really hardcore comic
book fans hate him but people who are
casual fans think he's interesting so
I'm kind of curious to see what what
side of the field you guys take on this
I like him I think he's a cool character
I think that he was kind of misused and
the New Avengers run when he was folded
over I think his best stories came out
of Marvel nights but you know I think
that he's still a pretty reasonable
character still decent I mean he's dead
now those of you guys who don't know by
the way I want to go ahead and bring
this up to you for those of you guys who
don't know the century dying in siege
was with the last time he officially
appeared in Marvel Comics he was kind of
resurrected as one of the four horsemen
I think as part of the apocalypse twins
but it wasn't really like this century
as we knew him the century as we knew
him ISM is essentially gone um the old
school century appeared in
the contest of Champions I think but
that doesn't count
like the the century as we know him is
is gone he's never been seen or heard
from again he may come back but I don't
think he will I think the centuries is
kind of gone he was a difficult
character to work with anyway it was
difficult to write stories for him
because he suffered from the Superman
complex but the fact remains you know
that that we may or may not see him at
some future point in time but we're not
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
please
[Music]